لأحد الخبراء يطلق عليها الخطة "ج"
لمحادثات غير مباشرة جديدة بين الولايات المتحدة
وإيران بهدف تقييد
البرنامج النووي الإيراني والسعي
لإطلاق سراح ثلاثة أمريكيين محتجزين،
أخبرت مصادر متعددة شبكة "سي إن إن" عن
الجهود المتجددة للتوصل إلى اتفاق
قائلة إن هناك بعض المؤشرات.
من التقدم ولكننا نضيف أيضًا أننا
لم نصل إلى هذه النقطة بعد، وفي الوقت نفسه قال البيت الأبيض
منذ أشهر إن إيران يمكن أن
تنتج ما يكفي من المواد لصنع
قنبلة نووية في غضون أسبوعين فقط، وربما
بشكل أسرع، ضيفي التالي هو
مؤلف حائز على جوائز يكتب  حول
سياسة الولايات المتحدة في الشرق الأوسط
وكتب أن إيران أقرب إلى
القنبلة من أي وقت مضى وفي مقال
سينشر في وقت لاحق اليوم
تقول تيريزا بارسي إن حقيقة أن
الاتفاق المكتوب والرسمي يبدو بعيد
المنال هو انعكاس لسياسة الولايات المتحدة في الشرق الأوسط.  كلا من الافتقار إلى
الإرادة السياسية والظروف المحلية والجيوسياسية المتغيرة،
فهو
ينضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة من فيرفاكس فيرجينيا
حيث هو المؤسس المشارك
ونائب الرئيس التنفيذي لمعهد كوينسي
للأبحاث غير الربحية المسؤولة عن إدارة الدولة ومراكز الأبحاث
الرائعة جدًا  هل أنت معنا لقد قرأت
مقالتك إنها حقًا مضيئة أعني أن
هناك تحذيرًا فيما يتعلق بما
يمكن أن يحدث إذا لم
تتحدث عن مستقبل
تيكرون لماذا تتخذ إدارة بايدن موقفًا
مختلفًا وأكثر
النهج الدبلوماسي الهادئ مع إيران في الوقت الحالي
جزء من السبب وراء
تحرك الإدارة بعناية في
هذا الاتجاه هو الاحتجاج
في إيران وبسبب دعم إيران
لروسيا، كان
من الصعب جدًا على إدارة بايدن من الناحية السياسية
أن تكون قادرة على التجديد.
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني وتمريره عبر
الكونجرس، لا يحظى إيفان بشعبية في
واشنطن بأي حال من
الأحوال بعد أن رأى كيف
قام النظام بقمع
الاحتجاجات بوحشية وعنيفة خلال
الشهرين الماضيين، فضلاً عن دعمه
لروسيا، الأمر الوحيد  لقد جعل الأمر
أسوأ بكثير، فمن ناحية، من الصعب تنفيذ
ذلك في واشنطن، وعدم
القيام بأي شيء هو أكثر خطورة
لأن الإيرانيين يمضون
قدمًا في برنامجهم النووي، لذا
فإن المجال الذي يبدو أن هناك بعض
الجدوى السياسية لتحقيقه فيه  إن القيام بذلك مع
تلبية الحاجة في الوقت نفسه
إلى منع المزيد من
التقدم النووي الإيراني هو التوصل إلى نوع من
الاتفاق غير الرسمي الذي
ينهي التصعيد بشكل أساسي،
وبالتالي
سيتم إطلاق سراح المواطنين الأمريكيين الثلاثة المحتجزين
كجزء من هذه الصفقة.
العديد من العناصر في هذا الأمر لا
يتعلق فقط بالنووي
بالتأكيد أه أعتقد أنه من الأهمية بمكان أن يتم
إطلاق سراح الأمريكيين الثلاثة المحتجزين ظلماً الأمريكيين الإيرانيين أه في إيران، حيث أن العديد منهم كانوا هناك
منذ عدة سنوات ولكن أكثر من سبع
سنوات في قضية واحدة أه وهو  حان الوقت
لعودتهم إلى الوطن
وستكون هناك ضغوط متزايدة على
الإدارة إذا لم
ينهوا ذلك، مع الأخذ في الاعتبار بشكل خاص حقيقة
أنهم كانوا سريعين إلى حد ما في إخراج
الأمريكيين من روسيا أه لذلك هذا
عنصر حاسم للغاية في كل  هذا ولكن
أثناء القيام بذلك يبدو أن
الجهد هو أيضًا التأكد من
عدم تجاوز الإيرانيين لتخصيب
اليورانيوم 60 والذي سيكون خطيرًا جدًا إذا فعلوا
أه من المحتمل أن يتوقفوا عن
زيادة مخزونهم 60 وفي
المقابل سيكون هناك أه هناك
لن يكون هناك تشديد للعقوبات كما هي
الآن،
وسيتم فك تجميد بعض أموال إيفون الخاصة، ليس
بمعنى أنها ستعود إلى طهران ولكن
بمعنى أن إيران يمكن أن تستخدم تلك الأموال
لشراء الطعام والغذاء.  الطب يصب في
تلك
النظرة ونحن نعلم أن الوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية تقوم حاليًا
بالكثير من العمل على أرض الواقع
لمعرفة بالضبط نوع
التخصيب الجاري. أريد أن أتحدث
عن صفقة 2015، أعني أننا نعلم أن
ذلك انهار  لقد رأينا تحولا كبيرا
أه منذ ذلك الحين ولكن دول إقليمية
بما في ذلك عمان
أم أبو ظبي تستضيف اجتماعات أيضا أم
وزير الخارجية السعودي على سبيل المثال
من المتوقع أن يسافر إلى طهران غدا
ما مدى أهمية الدعم الإقليمي في كل
هذا
النووي الأخير  التعامل مع الواحد من
2015 لم يحظى بدعم بعض
القوى الإقليمية أه السعودية والإمارات
وإسرائيل ولكن في بقية دول العالم
كان أمرا بديهيا بما في ذلك
القوى الإقليمية الأخرى مثل عمان التي ساعدت
أه في المراحل الأولى من  تلك
المفاوضات وكذلك قطر وغيرها
ولكن هذه الدول الثلاث أه كانت
تعارضها مما أدى الآن إلى تحول
السعوديين والإماراتيين الآن أكثر
انفتاحا على الأفكار التي لا
يزال الإسرائيليون هم الراسخين الوحيدين في معارضة
أي شكل من أشكال الاتفاق مع طهران  لكن
كل هذا يحدث الآن في
سياق قيام القوى الإقليمية
بتحسين العلاقات فيما
بينها أه لقد رأينا
التطبيع بين إيران
والسعودية يحسن العلاقات بين إيران
والإمارات وكذلك بين العديد من
الدول الأخرى في المنطقة  لذا فإن
المنطقة نفسها تتحرك نحو
نوع من التخلص من السموم الداخلية، وفي إطار ذلك
كان من المهم للإيرانيين
التأكد من عدم وجود
المزيد من التصعيد بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة لأن
ذلك يمكن أن
يمنع أو يقوض جهودهم
لتحسين العلاقات مع الولايات المتحدة.  جيرانهم
نعم أعني وقد شهدنا تحولات ضخمة
أه على المستوى الإقليمي أيضًا فيما يتعلق
بالعودة إلى The Fray، كما تعلم
هل هذا النهج الدبلوماسي سيتطلب
إشرافًا كبيرًا من الكونجرس وقد ألمحت حقًا إلى
الاحتجاج  العمل الذي رأيناه في
إيران نعرف القضايا الاجتماعية التي
تحدث الآن والفظائع
التي تحدث أه للإيرانيين
وبالطبع قضية المرأة
جزء من السبب الذي يجعلني أعتقد أن
الإدارة تتجه نحو اتفاق غير رسمي
هو أيضًا ليس مجرد
اتفاق نووي، بل على وجه التحديد لأنه
سيساعدهم على عدم الاضطرار إلى تمرير
هذا من خلال الكونجرس، وسيظل الكونجرس
يعلن أه آرائه بشأن هذا
الأمر ولكن لن يكون لديهم أي
سلطة رسمية ليتمكنوا من التدخل أو
التدخل في هذا  لو كان
برنامجًا نوويًا واسع النطاق، أو
اتفاقًا نوويًا، لكان يجب أن يمر عبر
الكونجرس وستتاح للكونغرس
فرصة للتصويت عليه، وسيكون ذلك
معركة دموية للغاية، معركة من
الواضح أن الإدارة ليست مستعدة
لجزء من السبب.  سبب قيامهم
بذلك هو أنهم يريدون السلام
والهدوء على الجبهة الإيرانية خلال الأشهر الثمانية عشر المقبلة
قبل الانتخابات.